emanuel mccomb visitó la catedral de
parís lo hizo vestido con un overol y
con un casco de protección en allí pudo
hablar con los arquitectos al frente de
este proyecto de reconstrucción y
también con los diferentes artesanos
entre ebanistas y talladores de piedra
quienes le contaron cómo ha sido esta
primera etapa una primera etapa que ha
sido la de consolidar el edificio es
decir estabilizar la estructura de la
catedral la reconstrucción debería
comenzar ya en forma a partir del
próximo mes de septiembre la
reconstrucción sobre todo de el tejado y
de la aguja que serán tal y como eran
antes del incendio en cuanto al
presupuesto se cuentan con 833 millones
de euros todo esto fruto de donaciones
que llegaron de todo el mundo en cuanto
al calendario se espera que no todas en
vuelva a abrir sus puertas a
público y oficiará misas el 15 de abril
de 2024 tal y como lo había prometido en
manuela marcó justamente el día después
de el incendio en 2019 pero lo cierto es
que la restauración tomará mucho más
tiempo que eso